you got a need with perseverance
don't give up oh because it's gonna be
delicious trust me
[Music]
hey guys i'm brenda i'm a tasty producer
i will be testing homemade versus
store-bought pasta i need to know is it
worth taking the extra time the extra
effort to make pasta from scratch is it
even better because if it's not better
come on so i'm just gonna get cooking in
here and you and i will take this
journey right now
[Music]
my first impression of homemade pasta
was does it really take just flour and
eggs to make this i mean come on
everybody has these two ingredients at
home the process also very simple you
make your flour volcano you gradually
add eggs and then you begin mixing
[Music]
so don't be afraid of getting your hands
dirty this is what happens when you play
with dough think of yourselves as a
kitten who happens to look like ed
sheeran i mean think about it ed sheeran
does look like a kitten
and this kitten meaning you you depend
on your kneading skills to survive you
know when kittens give little massages
that's what it is it's kneading and this
is what we need to do
well today to get
amazing
pasta dough
the entire process takes me around one
hour and a half that includes mixing
ingredients resting the dough flattening
cutting shaping your dough however it's
not a complicated process on the
contrary it's pretty entertaining
[Music]
this is an 80-something dollar machine
you can get one for around 30
and it'll get the job done you don't
need it you can do this entire thing by
hand but trust me this will make your
job smoother and a lot more fun
so here's the thing every time you run
the dough through the machine
you want to increase these little
numbers right here and the higher they
go the thinner the dough will get i
realized that seven is my ideal number
but a good way to guide yourself is to
stop when you see your fingers through
the dough
[Music]
all right so it comes down to the
store-bought version and we have right
here fettuccine from the box the
difference is evident this is thicker
it's no longer flowy and as far as i
understand
there are no eggs in here
[Music]
you can serve your fettuccine with any
pasta sauce but we think alfredo sauce
really highlights the properties of
fettuccine especially homemade
[Music]
all right let's break this down you know
in terms of price the store bought is
the winner time store-bought wins again
texture
the homemade version it's silkier
it's smoother in terms of preparation
this is very straight to the point you
open the box you put it in boiling water
blah blah blah you know how it goes here
you're gonna have some fun when i say
it's like play-doh for grown-ups i am
not lying now i also ask people on
instagram based on looks they would go
100
for the homemade version and i have to
agree with them you're gonna love it and
i guarantee it besides the flavor
a thousand times better i mean three out
of my three testers agree with me you're
really gonna love it
[Music]
oh my god
it's just so good i'm out of here have a
good day
[Music]